these sassy sophisticated solvent women
say they are struggling to find other
halves that measure up
um okay so we got
46 year old Lucy
uh 52 year old
Leslie
Julia 54 Laura 42 in J and 48 so it's so
crazy that women live to half a century
without any humility
do you see the language
um they're struggling to find other
halves that can measure up well maybe
you don't measure up I think this was in
2019 and the women over the age of like
35 I think only like a quarter of them
are unmarried or yeah I think it's only
a quarter so uh the majority of your
peers prioritize relationships at some
point
um so I don't want to be that person but
it might be you
I very well might be you let's look at
the Twitter comments let's see if
they're very sympathetic there are men
that would take these women they just
have to lower their standards
menworth discipline says they moved on
about 20 to 30 years ago
none of them look like they are young
enough to Bear children so they get the
leftovers their time has passed and you
know it's so crazy because even male
athletes kind of know when their times
passed right like the the NBA players
would be like okay it's time to pass on
the torch but women like that well it's
so funny they they blame men for a
lifetime instead of saying you know what
I pissed away my youth
I made very poor decisions I wasn't good
enough for a husband and this is what
you can learn instead they just point
the fingers and say the men don't
measure up and it's like what what are
their careers really that's my question
well all my life I was sure being smart
and having a career were the only things
worthwhile about me I've never been
attractive at all have been reminded of
that from a young age now I'm a gross
old hag no one will ever want but I
guess because I'm a virgin I can be yeah
no virginity doesn't count when you're
old it's like I mean what is a 50 year
old virgin worth I mean she can't have
kids like Lolo Jones it's like I'm a 40
year old virgin I'm like well at this
point you might as well just lose it
because you pissed away the youth it's
like virginity goes with youth otherwise
they just assume something's wrong with
you because it's like
uh nobody made the cut in 30 years not
one got like okay Leroy what were they
doing with the good men in their 20s
yeah and this is the problem
um a lot of women
think we're more attractive than we are
we refuse to settle and we just live in
delusion for a lifetime and older women
are really supposed to learn from their
mistakes and pass on humility to the
younger generation but what I see time
and time again is them still blaming the
men it's always the man's fault never
the women's fault and it's like we're
either equal or we're not equal if we
want to be equal then be equal deal with
the same problems the men deal with but
if you don't want to be equal and you
want special treatment stop whining I'm
just I could have a whole series called
women whining again you know there are
men that have exceptionally hard lives
like literally
such hard lives um you know they work in
oil rigs coal miners and you just don't
see them complain
you know men really do they suffer in
silence their wife gets fat they're not
attracted to their wife anymore they
suffer in silence their wife doesn't
sleep with them for three years they
stick it out they suffer in silence
where women whine 24 7 about everything
that goes wrong
everything that's why you see all these
Cairns
um coming out and just whining whining
whining whining poor me boohoo